hi everyone it's Jerry I have a nice
game to share with you from the 1993
lenares tournament
on the wide end world champion at the
time Gary Kasparov
and he's playing against gotta kamski
opening wise we have an open Sicilian
and in this one we work with a small
pond Center
he's gave it again variation
a very popular reply to this setup by
white is G4 the carries attack looking
to dislodge the king Knight
okay in this setup we have Bishop on E3
and F3 we go into an English attack
the reply here Knight B to D7
more popular nowadays Pawn advances B5
or H5 combating G4
okay black connects Knights
in comes G4
a move that's
all the more appealing with the queen
Knight committed to D7 if G5 is allowed
uh the king Knight no longer has its
favorite Retreat Square
okay
black says not so fast he secures his
night white preps though this Advance
right around the corner for white is H4
and then the next two moves will hit at
light speed G5 G6 don't blink this
structure can easily be broken down E6
can be a goner
what is black going to do to combat this
very idea I have mapped out
in the game it is Queen B6
he puts pressure on B2
the suggestion here is to yet again get
rolling with the B Pawn
let's see why this idea to put pressure
on B2 is ineffective these next two
moves by white I found instructive
how would you respond
to this threat feel free to pause the
video
okay the best move in this position move
played in the game A3
what is that move doing
White's last move controls B4
and A3
this is setting a queen trap one that
you would find
out of the French defense
after Knight A4 in this position the
queen is toast no safe squares
you'll notice if this Pawn is back home
the queen would have access to A3
or B4
okay
a convenient defense of B2 this A3 move
once queenside castles is in it's nice
to have that A2 Square as a flight
Square for the king
no holes created with this move either
all right we continue with 95
and let me throw this to you as a pop
quiz what move would you play here feel
free to pause the video
okay I want to draw some attention to
this position there's a couple tempting
moves here by white in the game
Bishop F2 is played
attempting move in this position is
Knight F5 defending the bishop attacking
the queen
computer says in this position you could
get away with taking on B2 King D2 turns
out to be an only reply for to stay as a
level position we go down some crazy
path where it's a
queen versus two Rooks inbounds forget
about all that black could simply play
in this position Queen C7 things are
cool here on D6 two attackers two
Defenders and white would have no better
than to go back to D4
also in reply to this move F4 is
tempting
but losing would be losing for white
because black can chop away on G4 and if
the queen is not here on home base
defending the Rook
Queen takes B2 black is winning one of
the unprotected pieces this line here
I'm highlighting helps us to understand
why in this position right here this
natural looking Queen D2 is ineffective
black could then get away with Queen
takes B2 no time for a queen trap there
would be a thread on The Rook
so in this game it is Bishop F2 it's
these two moves here A3 Bishop F2 that
address the pressure on B2
what's happening with this last move the
king is there defending the bishop now
Knight takes E6 is threatened
this is where the queen says fine
I'm out of here and only after white has
released the pressure on B2 does he give
the center Knight a kick
to C4
light Square Bishop moving for the first
time
capturing a knight that moved
three times get the recapture
Queen F3
E5 Knight F5 difficult position already
for team black what's considered best
here
H5 G5 Knight G4 that's as far as I'm
taking it
the move played in this game after
Knight F5 Bishop takes Knight we have
another case this is just an observation
I made about this game uh another case
here where the light Square Bishop is
moving for the first time to capture a
knight
that moved three times not sure exactly
why I'm drawing attention to this I am
looking at these squares a little bit
uh is there something to really take
away I'm not entirely sure but
you'll notice the recapturing piece is a
pawn is the recapture a queen is a
recapture I think we could say for
certain that white definitely benefits
with this move here opens up a file for
The Rook I'm not sure how great of an
improvement it is for the queen to be on
C4 rather than C7
anyhow just an observation
we continue play in the center F takes
E5 Knight takes E4
and this Rook is now put to work
along a rank
there's now a pin now this bishop would
like to move
as a responsibility though
so black gives The Rook a kick to a
different file
and now deploys the bishop but white has
a very cool
reply here he carries on
with development
how could he get away with this tactics
Bishop takes Bishop is the reply and now
Knight takes Knight
there's no time for Bishop takes Rook
there's a fork you would lose the queen
okay Pawn takes Knight Queen takes
Bishop let's pause 22 moves in in-game
position who stands better and why white
stands better
why does white stand better
well Rook positions that's one thing
that sticks out to me both white Rooks
functioning
black Rooks still in home base but the
bigger problem here
is that there is a huge question mark
over the black king
where will you find
A Safe Haven
the really
only exists a safe haven over here but
how do you get over here
this is this is an adequate structure A6
B7 the white king no problem nice and
cozy over here three pawns watching over
the white king
how do you get to the queen side
okay
we continue Rook C8 I had a look at this
move instead of Rick ca's Queen A2
anything to be worried about there's a
threat of a check and another check
no problems if Queen A2 though C3
we have a new square for the king
check King C2 we're firing right back at
the queen she just misplaced if she goes
in there
so it's Rook C8 in this game King B1 now
Rook d8 Rook takes Rook King takes Rook
pop quiz
important moment in the game how would
you approach this position what would
what would be your move
feel free to pause the video
okay
best move move played in the game
Rook H3
what is this move doing
white now is the king
wants to be over here he wants to hide
behind these ponds but the Rook is
saying
not so fast you go there I go here and
your queen is a goner
now
a move that ran through my mind I think
it's a moon move that many players would
think about here and that is to track
down this Pawn you could win the pawn
uh for instance you go Queen F4
and then you're going to win the pawn
next no matter what and the queen is
perfect in the center she'd be defending
everything
but the question is do we want a coin
exchange so for example let's let's just
make a couple moves this would be
excellent here but let's just say we go
in first sequence where we're exchanging
Queens why is this sequence not a good
choice for white
lights up a pawn but we're in a rook and
pond ending now maybe the best way to
say it is that with Queen still on board
the black position
the black king position is always in
question it's a negative no matter where
where the king is if he can't get again
over here it's always going to be a
liability
but with the Queens off
this guy his position is a positive all
of a sudden
this is exactly where he would want to
be
no fear of getting checkmated
and right around the corner in In This
Very position he could carve out a
square with G6 he would get the E6
Square
it's an even position despite being down
upon
King activity
is the big reason why
so white understands this he knows
I'm going after the King this is the
bigger prize who cares about a silly pun
Rook H3
you will not cross King excuse me Queen
D5 Rook C3
just in time to stop the king from
Crossing King D7 and now the pieces
sweeping coordinating on C7
in the game Rook d8
if you try Rook C8 you're going to lose
to E6 check this Rook is going to fall
after a sequence like this there we go
in simplified form
so in the game it's Rook d8 you see the
idea that King wants to now sneak over
here
so this move here is considered winning
but absolute best move played in the
game Rook C5
White's kicking the queen away from
defending B7
now something you can question in your
own games is moments where you attack
your opponent in some way something you
can question here
am I maybe helping my opponent
uh helping one of my opponents pieces or
pawns go to a square it wants to already
go to
so for instance if you're playing Rook
C7 here your cha you would be chasing
the king away to a square it wants to go
to let him go there on his own don't
help him don't give him a nudge in the
direction he wants to go
okay so in this one it is Rook C5
we get a check thrown in there the King
goes to E8
all on his own
Queen takes B7 up a pawn now ready to
win a second right around the corner
there's E6
so in the game it's Queen G4
if black tries E3 here E6 white is there
first how you stopping
Queen here
yeah
completely winning position for white
what is tried Queen G4
and it comes E6 F takes E6 Rook E5 let's
just pause for a moment give this guy
some credit
what a piece a rook right here in the
center how did he get there
uh
a lot of Tempe
made a lot of moves G1
G4 H4
h3c3c5 E5 he's got one more move in him
though before the game is over
okay the threat here is to take on E6
with check and then follow up with Queen
E7 check winning The Rook black defends
E7
and cool move here H4 flicked in
this is in a way demoting the queen
she's not as
um
mobile not as active on H4 compared to
G5 she's not defending G7 anymore and in
some cases she doesn't have access to D5
exchanging Queens even in a variation
like that white would still be winning
if it got got down to a rook and pawn
ending but H4 nice move flicked in here
the Queens are going to stay on
in the final position to this one
we now follow up with Rook takes E6
check King f8 and one final move a nice
touch
F6 a nice interference
black resigns there are two threats here
and black cannot Parry both
threat number one mate in one and threat
number two queen E7 check
winning The Rook
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it maybe took a thing
or two away
that's all for now take care bye